all right here's three productivity
themed iPhone features you probably
didn't know about so first normally when
you want to select a few things on an
Apple app you hit edit and then select a
few things one at a time but in any of
these you can just two-finger drag
select to pick as many things as you
want or unselect so that goes for memos
files messages and even Apple notes but
speaking of notes you probably use this
app for just writing stuff dying you
want to remember but if it's just text
in front of you hit the camera icon and
there's a scanned text feature which
will look at any text in front of you
and instantly translate it into typed
characters super useful for grabbing a
quick business card or something like
that but then my personal favorite is
called back tap so it's in settings
accessibility touch and then scroll down
to back tap and it's exactly what it
sounds like you can map things to a
double tap or triple tap of the back of
the phone so it's like adding an extra
button you can double tap to launch the
flashlight or triple tap for the camera
since the iPhone doesn't do a power
button shortcut like every other phone
you're welcome